يتخيل الأشخاص في الخارج الذين لا يعرفون شيئًا
عن صناعة الأزياء
أنك تجلس في الاستوديو الخاص
بك وأنت ترسم رسمًا بعيدًا ،
ثم ترسل تلك التصميمات إلى
المصنع الذي يصنعون الملابس
ويعودون ويظهرونها في
عرض الأزياء في
أي مكان قريب تمامًا  ماذا يحدث
لقد كنت أعمل في مجال الأزياء منذ
ما يقرب
من 13 عامًا ، 14 عامًا ،
يشغل جوناثان أندرسون دورين رفيعي المستوى
في صناعة الأزياء ،
إنه المدير الإبداعي لشركة lueve الإسبانية الفاخرة
بالإضافة إلى شركته التي يقع مقرها في لندن ، جي دبليو
أندرسون ،
ولكن  يمتد مجال تأثيره إلى
ما هو أبعد من هاتين العلامتين التجاريتين
بالنسبة لي ، الأمر كله يتعلق برسم الخرائط الذهنية.
مساعي أندرسون الإبداعية
على مدار السنوات التي عمل فيها مع علامات تجارية
مثل كونفيرس وأونيكلو
، أقام معارض مزج بين الفن
والأزياء
وكريم البطل.  بعد الأشخاص من مجموعة
من الوسائط
، يقول إن هذا النهج هو الذي
يخرجه من السرير في الصباح ، فأنا أستمتع
بالضغط على بعض الأشخاص الذين لا يستمتعون
بالضغط ولكني أحب الحوارات المستمرة
لأنني أشعر أن عتبة الملل لدي
قصيرة بشكل لا يصدق ، دعنا نضع ذلك  بطريقة
كل ما أفعله فيه ، يجب أن أكون
فضوليًا بشأن
ذلك ، يجب أن يكون هناك فضول للعثور على
الأشياء كل يوم ، عليك أن تجد
شيئًا جديدًا
عندما طُلب مني العمل مع montclair
genius ، أعتقد أنني كنت أنتظر وقتًا طويلاً في
الواقع.
علامة مونتكلير الإيطالية الصادقة التي اشتهرت بصنع
ملابس خارجية فاخرة خلقت
montclair genius منصة تدعو
المصممين المرموقين لإنشاء مجموعات خاصة
تحت اللقب العبقري الذي
أطلق هذه الملابس على مدار
العام ،
لقد كنت مهووسًا بالمشروع
لأن ريموند حقًا كان رائداً في طريقة جديدة للغاية
تناول التعاون
الذي جعله وكأنه منزل كان كما لو
أنني سأضع كل هؤلاء الأشخاص
في هذا المنزل ويمكنهم فعل أي
شيء  أريد أن ترسمه بهذا اللون
مهما كنت أظن أن المدير كان
ذكيًا ، كان مثل عدم التفكير بالنسبة لي ،
كما تعلم ، أعتقد دائمًا أن
التعاون لا يمكن أن يكون طريقًا ذا اتجاه واحد ،
يجب أن يكون اجتماعًا بين
عقلين  يجب أن يكون معنى لعلامتين
تجاريتين لا يمكن لأحدهما التغلب على الآخر في
القانون ، وأعتقد أنه صفحة فارغة
وليس هناك
حدود وأعتقد أن هذا هو سبب
نجاحه لأنك تعلم أن المصمم يكره
المعلمات
[الموسيقى]
حسنًا ، أعتقد أن الموضة تدور دائمًا
المسافة هي دائمًا المسافة ، إنها
دائمًا تتعلق بخلق الرغبة ، إنها مثل
الفن بطريقة مماثلة والتي تشبه
كيف تخلق الرغبة من شيء
لا يمكنك
بلوغه
أحيانًا ولكن في بعض الأحيان أعتقد أنه يتعين علينا
تقسيمها أكثر قليلاً و  اشرح
ما تفعله الموضة ،
أعتقد حقًا أن الناس
يريدون الأصالة وأعتقد أنهم يريدونك
أن تكون حقيقيًا وفي نفس الوقت أعتقد أنه
خلال هذه اللحظة أعتقد أننا نريد
التعاطف ، فهذه تحديات كبيرة ليس
حتى للموضة فقط  التفكير في الصناعة
بشكل عام
[الموسيقى]
بالنسبة لي ، تعد الحرف اليدوية أحد
الركائز الأساسية للإبداع في صنع أعتقد أن
الموضة تدور حول صنعها
عندما بدأت علامتي التجارية الخاصة على سبيل المثال ،
فقد جمعت دائمًا حرفة إما
سلال أو سيراميك أو أي شيء
يبدو أنه هناك  هو شخص لديه
مقاربة عالية المهارة في التعامل مع
أيديهم والتي كانت دائمًا محيرة بالنسبة لي ،
فقد وجدت دائمًا
فكرة رائعة عن القدرة على
إظهار شيء ما من مادة خام إلى
سلعة نهائية
[موسيقى] ،
وأنا سعيد لأنني  تمسك بهذه
الفلسفة القائلة بأن الفكرة هي أن
التصميم هو المهم ، وتأتي العلامة التجارية في
المرتبة الثانية
ولهذا أعتقد أن دور المدير الإبداعي
قد تغير
[موسيقى]